we're so excited that you're here i i
can tell you guys have been
deprived of humans
it's just been awesome when you walked
out we were like ah
i don't even know what to do heidi
you're not wrong you're absolutely right
we have been deprived
of humans however you're like it's like
being in church like at saturday night
live is my church
and you know you're a legend and you're
just crushing it
wasn't it true that you like were said
in your yearbook like most likely to end
up on saturday night live
it is true
wow yeah okay
heidi will you hit some headlines with
us love yes all right
okay first up i love this story about
dan levy he recently hosted snl for the
first time in entertainment weekly
reports that before he left
dan wrote a little note for the next
host of saturday night live regina
king and then she left one
heidi take it away tell us what happened
you're you're there yeah you don't need
entertainment with me
you are literally right there i'm right
there break it down so then
regina leaves one for reggae jean paige
then reggae jean paige leaves on for
nick jonas
and it's just like the and it's all just
little like good luck have fun
um just like being sweet to each other
i love this so much it's like when
presidents leave you know after their
four years or eight years they leave a
little note in the desk for the next
president this is so brilliant
hosting snl i can't even imagine what
that's like so if you've never done it
the fact that you could leave a little
note
a guidance for the next person is
beautiful yes
and it's so dan leavy like he's so sweet
like when he hosted
i i was coming in to like talk to him
about something and before i left he was
like
do you want a cookie and i was like yes
i want a cookie and then we rehearsed
we rehearsed for like five more hours
that day at the end of the night it's
like 11 he's like
come get another cookie and i was like
you are so nice
wow you just fed me the whole week i
think that we should take a page
pun intended from uh dan levy's idea and
just start doing this
it's like this pay it forward yet
connect
back it's so wonderful mm-hmm yeah
this is the next story the next story
comes to us from china and it's working
huge conversation on chinese social
media and i want your thoughts
the new york post reports a divorce
court has ordered a man to pay his wife
seven thousand seven hundred dollars for
her housework
after five years of marriage and it's
part of a new divorce law that says a
partner who
takes on the unpaid work caring for the
kids caring for the elderly or helping
with
the partner's job is entitled to
compensation
you have to think about the time the
effort all that hard work that the
partner that doesn't
work uh at a traditional job puts in
it has to be of value and is it monetary
i i mean i've never heard of anything
like this heidi what do you think
i think heck yeah yeah just the amount
of amazon packaging
my husband leaves around when he opens
something and i have a job like and i'm
picking that up i'm like
i would like money for that yes
um okay everybody grab a banana
okay
because it's time for food news okay
um may i ask what's the first thing you
want to do when you grab a banana
call my nana
okay but a writer of refinery29 went on
a quest to determine the correct way
to peel a banana and the answer might
surprise you
heidi can you read that tell us what it
says it's from the bottom
up no this is that shocked me this is
bananas that's
crazy from down here apparently we've
been doing it
all wrong apparently going backwards
going the other way around avoids that
mealy tip
what do you think heidi well i also find
the bottom to be mealy and i cut that
off too
so i only eat a banana like in them
this much have you ever peeled it from
the bottom i have not
let's do it all right here we go it
feels wrong
oh my god it's so much better and so
much more delicate to not
crank on the handle i didn't like that
it just felt like against nature ross
i'm
totally with you right i say no yeah no
i'm good
okay yeah yeah this banana can split
[Applause]
i'm so stupid heidi would you like to
read the next story
do it um yes i would love to well
we clearly love a good snack on this
show me included i'm new but i love it
so this next story is right down our
alley the guardian reports people have
found a new way to pin pal
by sharing snacks it started on reddit
and basically you can link up with
someone across the globe and swap snacks
with them so someone in australia could
trade you vegemite
and some emu jerky for your flaming hot
cheetos uh
sign me up yes are you kidding me the
only thing i like more than friends is
food
you know this is perfect anyone in
germany want to send me a
kraut yeah whatever schnitzel that one
of those i should find
yeah well three of those thank you no
i'm good
[Laughter]
isn't this fun think about that you can
meet people from the world and try
all the different cuisine and more than
just the cuisine the snacks
right because they're so different
everywhere heidi you have a really
special pen pal story
and you started doing it in the pandemic
will you tell us about it
yes so right when the pandemic started
and we were all
at home and didn't know what to do i was
like what can i do to
help right now and i was like i bet um
senior citizens are really lonely right
now in retirement homes so
i started writing them letters and cards
and you know i did it as a way to give
back but of course
when you give you receive so much more
and like then the
rest of the months during the gimmick
i've been getting letters
from people all across the country um
one of them her name's vera in cascade
iowa
and there are some women in kansas city
who like we write to each other about
alanis morissette songs i mean it's been
very cool and and therapeutic everything
you just said was so heartfelt and it
it just changed my body language and the
feeling i had inside because it's so
positive and good and connective and
i'm so glad that you did that and i
would love to jump on the snail mail
train with you
oh my god you've got a right to vera too
i would love to write to vera that's
sweet
i'm in um okay and next heidi you
actually brought us
a delicious snack we don't even have to
pen palette you brought it right
here yes um so this is from my
hometown kansas city missouri and if
anyone knows me i love my hometown so
much and we are famous for barbecue
one of my favorites is arthur bryant's
and these are their
famous burnt inns that i've brought for
you so excited and i
do know that you are such a kansas city
patriot
i really am yeah you really are i love
that
mm-hmm you're going to die oh my god
the one of the things that's so amazing
if a barbecue sauce can really come
up into your like old factories and kind
of circle up into the nostril
and be like almost like a wasabi like
experience yes this is
unbelievable heidi yes thank you oh
you're welcome
i am just so honored you would come here
heidi is on snl obviously saturdays at
11
30 eastern 10 30 central
you